hello and welcome back to murder mystery
mood or just murder mood where we tell
i i like triple m mm-hmm
welcome back to where the store is
and the drinks
[Music]
today we're drinking what has i've heard
this drink called
several different things but the most
recent has been the panty dropper drink
so it's one of my favorite go-to drinks
because it's so simple to make
it's just three ingredients you're gonna
want about an ounce and a half to two
ounces of whipped cream vodka you could
be a little heavy-handed because it's
it's gonna get masked three ounces of
pineapple juice
and then a splash of grenadine what i
usually do is just fill a glass up with
ice
put 1.5 ounces of whipped cream vodka in
there and then just fill the rest
up with pineapple juice and then do the
splash of grenadine and then you just
shake it once
and then that's your drink this is so
good i love the color and you guys have
requested this
and i guess you liked it so we're coming
back and giving you
another episode and this time it will be
hosted by our very own
gina darling who also happens to be
obsessed with murder mystery and moods
obsessed so ever since i was young i
used to love watching like bloody gory
videos i love reading about serial
killers like this is
my jam so um i remember this is actually
one of the most prominent things i've
ever seen when i was little that kind of
stuck to my mind
i had actually when i was young
younger when this happened when i saw
this video yeah younger than now yeah
yeah i know i'm like so young right now
but can you believe i was even younger
it was like practically a toddler
wow this is one of those videos that you
probably should have never seen but i
watched it because i love stuff like
this um this is the story of
luca magnata his name is luca rocco
magnata
and by the name is quite a name is that
italian
uh so it was a name that he gave himself
he changed it officially afterwards
he's already a sociopath yeah okay go
ahead magnum girl you don't even know
i can't i've never heard this story so
like everything i haven't heard any of
this either okay so the only reason
the only reason why i know of luca
magnata is because netflix did an entire
documentary around him
called don't [ __ ] with cats on the
internet or something like that
something like that yeah so i like i saw
the entire
don't [ __ ] with cats okay so i get to go
home and watch the netflix
oh it's excellent does he kill cats well
well let's get into that
so luca was not born luca i don't know
what his real name was exactly because i
was thrown into this episode today so i
don't know she was like
we're telling stories i got so many i'm
like can you tell i got stories
um but this is like don't worry gina i
saw the documentary i'm an expert
this one stuck out with me because i got
to see the video there was a murder
video
uh so luca is this canadian guy
and he has always been insanely
narcissistic
he was all about looks he wanted to be a
male model and he was willing to do
anything to get famous
so he has a string of crimes on his name
already
uh first starting off was um fraud
so he met this woman online who had the
mental capacity of about an
eight-year-old but she had like credit
cards and all that so he ran up her
bills so around ten thousand dollars
just spending all on like just
luxurious things he even auditioned to
be on
a reality show about plastic surgeries
that was pretty much like botched
or something because he wanted to be a
male model and be famous so bad
that this is all he wanted later wait
what decade or what time
this is around 2010 2012 oh it's recent
oh this is recent well i don't like
these recent ones guys can we get some i
told you i like the old [ __ ]
i don't want it to be irrelevant to my
life you're upsetting the spirits
you see see that uh one of his first
strings of crimes or
one of the first things he did was fraud
and he stole a bunch of money
uh spent a bunch of it on just luxurious
crap that he didn't need
and then uh but then it started getting
worse uh
a video appeared on the internet called
one boy two cats
of which i don't like that
yeah yeah it's pretty bad in fact there
were multiple videos
of him uh murdering cats one of which he
duct taped the one to the broomstick and
held it underwater and drowned it
no what the [ __ ] you didn't say what he
did to the first one
in the first one the first one was oh
there was another one where he fed a
kitten to a python
and then there was another one where he
was it was something he i
from what i remember is that he stuck a
kitten
inside of a bag oh yes so those vacuum
seal bags he suck a kitten and vacuum
seal a seal bag
sucked out all the air and uh pretty
much they suffocated and they died
so these videos made their rounds online
and it got the attention of obviously
people who were very angry about this
and so the internet loves cats yeah
exactly don't [ __ ] with cats very angry
right now and that's why the documentary
is called don't [ __ ] with cats
because that vid those videos sparked
online
outrage where all these people came
together and they were determined to
find out who this guy was yeah they
created a whole facebook group
and they were just looking at every
single tiny detail
um and then like they they were
incredible what they did
in fact there was at one point where
they spotted a vacuum in the background
of a video of his
and they went online apparently there
are forums for vacuum enthusiasts yeah
yeah there is two reasons really
good at finding things and it just shows
you that there's so many people out
there with all kinds of interests
so um those people on the forum are like
okay so look this
model is only sold in this area the
country in this workplace whatever so
they
were able to track him down to what city
he lived in
and so uh these you know internet
investigators
the entire investigation though with the
documentary it's so interesting because
it's it's being told from the
perspective of these these people from
the facebook group so you get to see
their entire reaction of like
oh they first saw the video they got
upset they created a facebook group they
ended up going in
and investigating every tiny little
detail that they saw in these videos to
the point where
like do you know saying the vacuum thing
yes then also it led them to different
countries of the world
and they were just like where is this
person who the [ __ ] is this person and
it was just like the biggest mystery for
a few years i think right yeah so for a
long time they couldn't find him but
uh so they reported their findings to
the local police and where he actually
lived but the police were like well he
hasn't really
it's you know it's just cats because
whatever the [ __ ] right they didn't
really yeah
no animal abuse laws there i don't know
like not worth trying to prove
in court or something yeah they
eventually were able to find this guy's
name
and this guy just turned out to be an
insane sociopath he had literally
hundreds of fake accounts where he would
talk about himself and
try to be like a celebrity he had like
hundreds of pictures of him in miami
milan and all that stuff
so it was photoshopped in and then
photoshopped himself in milan yeah he
was a loser like he just
this guy was a [ __ ] loser oh there's
a lot of them out there
yeah like just photoshopping the big sky
boys
i know you're watching yeah they
eventually just found all these like
they realized that he made all these
fake accounts to try to make himself
sound like a celebrity
and he even started a rumor that he was
dating a very
uh well-known murderer that's currently
incarcerated in canada
and that murder murderer had to come on
be like i don't know this guy
what the [ __ ] he just got rejected right
i have standards right
and uh luca has gotten so many plastic
surgeries it was wild like he didn't
even look exactly what he looked like in
the beginning of this anymore weird
you know the cops were kind of like okay
it's not that big of a deal but you know
they're they
the people on the internet were kind of
concerned like look if it starts with
cats it's gonna get worse yeah
and eventually it did get worse because
if you don't show emotion while you're
torturing
small animals yeah that's a huge sign of
that's definitely a gateway exactly i
mean it's one thing to be torturing the
animal is another thing to not even have
any sort of reaction
exactly that's crazy
so eventually it does take a turn for
the worse
there was a chinese exchange student
named jun lin from wuhan china
who came from wuhan yeah yep
whose was 2012. yeah this is way back
when
so eventually there's a student named
jun lin he was a chinese exchange
student that met luca magnata and you
know
luca was like hey why don't you come
back to my place you know like they met
on
tinder or something they met on a dating
website or they met online
yeah i'm deleting all my dating apps
yeah they met online and then eventually
luca you know lured him back to his
apartment and this is where
uh he eventually killed jun lin
so this would have been what they're
assuming is his first human murder ever
and not only that
he also released an 11 minute video of
what he did to the body and i've seen
this video many many times oh my gosh
and i can tell you right now that it is
a bad
video uh it was it was lovingly labeled
um
uh one man one ice pick or like oh my
god
he keeps filming himself doing this
stuff and yeah why is he like obsessed
with the two girls one cup porno it's
because he
really wanted to get a lot of people
that want notoriety they want to get
caught yeah so but like but like why is
it that based off the two girls one cup
[ __ ] for seo it was yeah for seo
because it was already viral this guy's
a
internet genius okay like if he was
the sickest porn too yeah he had like
hundreds and hundreds of fan pages for
himself when he created them that he
created
so this video i'm going to try to
explain to you guys what's going on this
video real quick um
i really highly suggest that you guys do
not look up this video because it's
pretty [ __ ] bad
uh unfortunately in the he made it into
like a he there was no sound it was just
music and unfortunately it was music
from one of my most favorite bands in
the world to push mode
i love depeche mode um so it starts off
like there's a video
there's a it looks like a bed in you
know a bed so you're you're looking at
the lower left-hand corner of the bed
right so where the left foot would be
right
and there is a body there eventually you
just see him kind of like
it was so casual for him just coming in
dancing
you know to the music lucas yeah luke
was just dancing while there was a body
is it so i can kind of uh it was faith
it was something i used to think
morning sun
yeah that song wait he put that music in
there yeah he put the music in there i
gotta say
was it playing in the background i think
he i mean what i remember he it was
edited in
he's a great editor okay so
aesthetically i'm
kind of digging it but i don't like the
content
she's like i would go for him
great music i probably would have
partied with him but
great music taste um and then there is a
body laying on the bed
and he's just dancing while casually
just poking and stabbing it with an ice
pick
oh in the chest cavity yeah like in the
chest area he's just stabbing just
having a great time grand old time
uh poking or stabbing those stabbings
just stabby stabbing in there just
having fun with it all right
and the body will be reacting body's not
really it is like a movie this is dead
he was he was dead except for usually i
don't film it and put on the internet
yeah this is so creepy and then uh and
then it eventually goes to
him cutting off the head and each you
saw this gina
i love this stuff what yeah wait is that
excuse me crazy
no i mean it's for me it's just like i
have no desire to do this i don't get
turned on i don't have any like
you're just fast attracted by that
fascinated yeah
i do it's like that feeling you're
addicted to that feeling in your stomach
that's like oh no i want to turn away
but i can't
yeah it's one of those i could a little
bit relate to that because i like
watching like
caught in real life like cctv footage
okay ghost or whatever right but
not this wait what like i mean
the fact that it's like scary for me i'm
like oh
it's a little exciting that i'm scared
adrenaline
really how bad it is yeah that's why i'm
like i think i can relate a little bit
to what gina is talking about
through that i i guess i can relate a
little because i love
watching true crime and like reading
true crime but i couldn't watch like an
actual video of yeah i can't walk i just
picture
like so when i watch scary movies and
there's these like horrible murder
scenes and stuff like in scary movies i
just kind of like close my eyes
i kind of sometimes i don't because i'm
not like sorry my bad
what my other favorite band it was not
depeche mode sorry to pass your safe it
was a new order sorry
uh very similar it's a similar era
same era oh yeah yeah that is yeah it is
that song but it's new order sorry
i love that song blue monday is great
i was saying like i just don't react to
um like syrian movies
um like when they're like murdering a
body and like it's fake you know like i
know it's fake
you're like they're actors so i wonder
if i watch a real murder
if i were your descendants that or if my
body
would know that it's real but we've got
such good scary movies that
you know i even close my eyes during
boxing matches because like i
yeah i don't really like it i don't like
watch people get hurt right
same i like it simply because it's very
well i'm like morbidly curious about it
but it also makes me more aware
of my mortality and it makes me more
aware of what is going on out there
that's like man people can be [ __ ] up
i think that's why i do like i like
reading about it and watching right true
crime docs because i
i want to know that there's like the
details of the kind of people we're
dealing with out there
like what kind of people what kind of
backgrounds do these people have like
what's their mentality their mental
state like what's their motive avoid
psychos
so yeah i heard i read something
somewhere i forgot what it was exactly
but
it was some statistic that most serial
killers
or like murderers they end up being
sagittarius
oh like wait is that for real i don't
know i read that
somewhere i don't know how true it is
you guys could correct me but i remember
reading something about like
they're born and sleep on your guys's
room month of november
or something [ __ ] listen scorpios and
sagittarius couldn't be more different
which one is it it was something about
november or sagittarius i just remember
being connected to it somehow in me
thinking
oh my gosh i'm i'm like connected
there's a level of
like serial killers for each sign
yeah like can we look that up because i
want to know so speaking of his
background
luca was a little bit messed up in the
head already when he was younger his he
it was reported that his mother was
extremely clean like very very clean so
obviously a control freak right
and one of the prominent one of the main
things that kind of set him off they
said was
he had a couple of pets i think it was
bunnies when he was little and his mom
left him outside to freeze to death and
he saw them freeze to death out there
so he already has some mama issues right
anyhow back to the video
sorry correction it was a new order song
great band by the way saw him alive
older [ __ ] love them
yeah um so it went from the ice pick
just constant stabbing of the ice pick
to uh dismembering his body parts
um and what i i don't remember it was a
giant knife it was some sort of blade
wow so he cut off the head yeah
and it wasn't like clean oh wait a
second i think i heard about this
are you so excited gina why are you
smiling gina
sometimes people imagine
you know like but i'm literally a foot
away from her our beds are super close
yeah the bed is not a barrier
uh what were we saying now that you
you're saying these other things i think
i have
actually seen clips but not the actual
right
hurting parts it's just like clips or
pictures
screen caps of this of this situation
and it's grossing me out did he use his
hand to masturbate himself
so he did use his hands for a few things
um
and then also in the back of the bed on
the wall by the bed where the head is
there's a casablanca
poster if you remember that i don't
remember that yeah i remember from the
documentary he was a big movie buff and
he loved that movie
so um so the directors of casablanca are
to blame yeah exactly 100
yeah well i'm counting these they do
believe that a lot of his
choices was heavily influenced by the
movies that he loved so much
the names that he chose what movies have
a [ __ ] psycho prancing around a new
order stabbing a dead body with an ice
pick or the fake names that he chose
is what it is like it was inspired by
from like the fake fan pages and stuff
mm-hmm yeah he also let a a dog come in
i guess he had a dog
oh jesus and let the dog chew on the
body no
no no no yeah the [ __ ] is this video
yeah and then uh police uh the
investigators also said that there was
actually an extended version of the
video that was never released but they
saw
why didn't they release that one it was
leaked
like i think luca actually uploaded
himself and there was actually like an
extended version where
uh cannibalism was confirmed so he did
eat my body yeah
i didn't hear that part yeah so
throughout the next few months or so
um boxes started this was his first
human murder
so they say so we know so far yeah very
comfortable
oh yeah is he on drugs so
uh he was online he was just insane he
was insane
so crazy over the next few months um
boxes mysterious boxes started showing
up in the mail at elementary schools
offices of parliament um like uh what is
it parliament
oh cause they're in canada canada yeah
whatever it is they use over there king
or whatever the [ __ ]
moose uh and they have or like you know
political offices and stuff and
there was a foot in one there was a hand
in the other there were notes that said
something similar to once you get the
taste of blood it is impossible to stop
um basically tell them like look man i'm
not gonna stop it's gonna keep going so
you come and catch me already
like i've been i'm tired of killing cats
yeah i've killed
a person now you want me to keep killing
come get me eventually
they found his they found the head by
the shore of some
body of water they found a torso also
and so
now finally there was like a giant
manhunt for him the police are
definitely looking for him and they
finally
got to the apartment that this happened
in
but by the time they got there he was
already long gone uh
he was gone for like four four i want to
say like for for a while he was already
gone
so they found the apartment they found
traces of blood uh
and they found that in his closet he
wrote
in red lettering said um
if you don't like the way you look then
don't look in the mirror i don't care
what i don't but you know like image is
a very big thing for him
don't like the way you look in the
mirror i wonder what houses venus is in
do you think mercury was in retrograde
when this murder was going down yeah
yeah venus was i don't like that
gatorade yeah so uh by then he had
already left the country
and he had um he had to come to the us
he went to
france yeah oh mm-hmm
[Laughter]
oh oh that's what i say to you
um so eventually he goes to france
and uh he was already under like a fake
name and everything
right so he's he's happy did he pick a
french name i don't remember
i don't quite remember what name he had
terrible names uh francois pierre la
papilla
what is it magneto
um so at this point he already had like
a new passport new name and everything
how did he get this [ __ ] i have no idea
get a new passport yeah
no clue good at photoshopping yeah so
and here he had already had
you know friends in france that he was
that he knew before when he
he went there before and so he stayed
with them for a little bit make friends
i know sociopaths are weird sociopaths
are incredible they're very charismatic
yeah insanely charismatic okay like
sometimes when i'm hungry i get really
mad because
i like don't want to go make something
to eat
i'm but my hunger is like getting in the
way of my productivity
so i have a daily harvest in the freezer
and it is a literal lifesaver like i
don't
i don't know how i would function
without it like i sometimes i just i'm
like
i'm not gonna cook anything because i'll
just scream at the oven
um so daily harvest delivers delicious
food built on
organic fruits and vegetables and they
deliver it right to your door
it just takes a few minutes to prepare
and i never have to question if the food
i'm eating is good for me because it is
it's organic and it's also vegan
it's plant-based so don't have to worry
about that either
they never use preservatives they or
added sugar or artificial ingredients
they're just
great okay they what is it called when
they
flash freeze yeah they flash freeze
their their [ __ ] and then they put it in
a thing for you and it's so delicious
my favorite one is the broccoli and
cheese
cheese is spelt with a z because it's
not like dairy cheese it's like
made with cashew nuts and stuff it's
delicious it tastes like cheese and it's
amazing
and i can't get enough of it when i was
a kid my favorite food was broccoli and
everyone made fun of me but
it's still my favorite food i think
broccoli and cheese man that's where
it's at
it had it has like some sunflower seeds
in it too it's just great it has that
just the perfect amount of crunch
anyway i'm not going to keep talking
about it you got to check it out for
yourself
daily harvest makes it easy to eat clean
undeniably delicious food no matter what
your day brings
keep it simple with daily harvest go to
dailyharvest.com and enter promo code
big mood
to get 25 off your first box that's
promo code big boot for 25
off your first box at
dailyharvest.comdailyharvest.com
promo code first of all we want to give
a shout out to
skillshare which is an online learning
community
they offer creative classes designed for
real life and circumstances that come
with it
the lessons can help you stay inspired
express yourself and introduce you to a
community of
millions personally i've been having
issues
during quarantine with productivity i
don't know why
my like i just can't focus anymore on
anything
but so i was like i need to dial it down
i've got a lot of things i want to get
done
so there's a class called real
productivity how to build habits that
last
taught by thomas frank i just started
this one but i feel like it's
even just taking the class is kind of
helping me focus in like
i need to i need to stop being on uh
instagram all day long so i think
it's just a good way to start like
putting your head back into the right
frame of mind they also have tons of
other classes on literally anything you
could think of like illustration graphic
design
freelance film and video all kinds of
stuff skillshare offers memberships
with meaning with so much to explore
real projects to create and the support
of fellow creatives
skillshare empowers you to accomplish
real growth it's also incredibly
affordable
an annual subscription is less than ten
dollars a month explore your creativity
at skillshare.com
big mood girls and the first 1000 people
to use our link will get a free trial of
the skillshare premium
membership receive access to thousands
of classes for a limited time
be one of the first thousand to sign up
at skillshare.com
big mood girls and uh so he stayed in
france for quite a little bit
but you know they were able to track
down his flight to france
um they couldn't find him though and
then about within like
in the span of like a week or a couple
weeks or so they finally
spotted he was all over the news
and he went to a local pc cafe
uh to look himself up because that's how
insanely narcissistic he was he wanted
to read all these articles
basically he wanted to be famous he
wanted he wants to see all these
articles about himself he was just
totally getting off on the fact that he
was
famous now you know like everyone was
looking for him infamous yeah
i don't think the news should like show
all this to people yeah because or like
not disclose names or some
or something exactly because they spark
like copycats too
um and that's why a few of the body
parts that were sent they actually
the police did not disclose what body
parts to prevent
copy copycats from doing the same thing
so he checked into this pc cafe and the
owner
the clerk working there recognized him
and was like oh crap that's him and then
check them in let him use the computer
but then called the cops on the side and
the cops eventually came in
and uh found him searching for himself
on the internet
and he was extradited back to canada and
was charged he pled not guilty
okay even though there's a [ __ ] video
he's a comedian too
yeah yeah right amazing extremely
delusional amazing
uh so he played not guilty but he was
charged with a mandatory life sentence
with
uh i think i no no possibility of parole
of some sort
and then an additional 19 years but uh
happy news uh he got married in prison
what yeah dude these prison [ __ ] like
um there's
like prison fans that are oh no no no he
married another inmate
what another woman a man yeah he was gay
yeah he's gay another inmate that uh was
also a murderer
yeah they were hooking up oh like
grinder or something yeah okay
so he got married um to another murderer
so
hooray they have a lot of common
interests yeah
you could probably like have these crazy
conversations and get all turned on
yeah if you were out on the outside what
would you do
right but there were so twisted there
were
he got a lot of like those prison
[ __ ] that love [ __ ] like this
yeah dude pretty worships are the worst
like how do you like people like this
they get so much fan mail it's so weird
and i feel like prisons you know because
they are supposed to screen
the the mail that the prisoners get
anyway i know i know they usually just
kind of open it and then like check for
drugs and like yeah
rapid check [ __ ] but i feel like they
should be reading these letters
and whatever women are writing these
letters should also be arrested i don't
know
no honestly do anything wrong honestly
they should you can't be
that would violate that's a precedent of
uh free will like taking away different
rights uh
i agree that you should be able to write
letters to people in prison
um of whatever you want to write but um
i just think i think you're a [ __ ] up
person i'm i'm gonna just uh
judge you right now that if you
are in love and obsessed with serial
killer or gina's like that's me that
says dungeons
that's not talking about if you write a
letter if you're the the level of like
wanting to marry
yeah these psycho like ted bunny you
know what i think it is
i think it's it's the fact that it's so
taboo
that they actually can't have these men
and the fact that they
are infamous or whatever it is like
that's probably the thing that turns
them on
i hope is not the part that are actually
killing people
i remember i tweeted something once that
i tweeted something saying
if you think you're better than someone
just because you have a college degree
please shut the [ __ ] up because even ted
bundy had one
and then ted bundy fan girls started
tweeting at me
what what is that supposed to mean like
that's so [ __ ] stupid like they were
actually fan girls and they had like
accounts that are fans of him
you guys need to calm the [ __ ] down like
this is really why are you protecting
him
oh that's creepy yeah so he got married
um
and then also like there's so many just
fans of his
which drives me insane because like that
just makes him happier
in fact making this episode oh yeah in
fact making this episode we'll probably
do it exactly so yeah you
[ __ ] prison [ __ ] yeah yeah he did
that oh i just got a really creepy he's
not allowed to watch
it down my spine thinking that he could
possibly be watching
this right now yeah but then also well
they might i don't know
so far i'm with you no new cases is he
still alive
he i think he is still alive yeah he's
still alive in there don't look at me
look away
don't look at a just understand that for
as long as you're in prison you're never
gonna be able to get plastic surgery
ever again so you're gonna get old
yeah i'm just kidding he sends his fans
to us oh my god seriously
right um so yeah that's why i was
thinking this episode i'm like this is
exactly what he wants
you know but um what can you do but like
i said gave it to him
yeah so he gave it to him are you i love
this stuff
imagine the prison [ __ ] i'm like the
head of the fan club
the prison [ __ ] and i just now found
out like that person should be arrested
he's like first amendment right
my freedom of speech here according to
the office
you know remember that episode they're
like whoever [ __ ] says who comes in
and says like the worst [ __ ]
punishment
is the one who's not guilty right oh
do you remember that episode i don't
remember i don't watch the office i
don't know i don't remember that
you made that episode up yeah
where like someone did something i can't
remember but um the
they were just like oh whoever who like
we're gonna interview everyone and say
what what should we do with the person
who's guilty and then so everyone that
comes in if they say oh they should go
to jail
worst punishment ever then they're not
guilty because they wouldn't
get that to themselves yeah but if
they're guilty then they would be like
oh we should go light on them you know
just let take it easy on them
it sounds vaguely from familiar it
sounds like michael would be the one
that was michael went like
jail and then he got wrapped into it so
he went back on it later but anyways
you guys guilty why
why you said i don't think they need to
go to a giant oh
that's true i believe in your your
rights
yeah the constitution worship of murder
push them out
your rights whatever you want you know
you have a right to whatever religion
whatever you want to believe in whatever
kind of protection
as long as it doesn't on someone else's
life nope they should die if they are
threatening other people or if the
letters say
i will carry out your wishes of
worshipping
someone that could dance around to a new
order song and ice pick a dead body
if you like that you deserve to die oh
here let me show you his picture you
guys haven't seen his picture just yet
you got to see how this guy looks look
at him i don't want to see him he's like
some wannabe pretty boy it's like
yeah he's like a wannabe boy band kind
of dude
like why didn't you go try to be famous
doing something else then
you really didn't try no he tried to be
a model he tried to
i think he even tried acting or
something but no one wanted like if you
took eminem and like pinched his face
oh no oh
wow he looks like such a little [ __ ]
we hate him yep that's
i can see why they would find him
attractive because he's not a terrible
looking guy
it's just the [ __ ] that he does he kind
of looks like my brother you'd be
no the the creepiest thing about him in
my opinion it's not even how he
looks obviously his actions but also the
way that he speaks
when he's talking it's [ __ ] creepy
yeah it really creeps me out how does he
speak because he talks like
yes and like i am very like supportive
oh very nice he wants to be
so i don't know it's like
what was his childhood like do we have
any information on yes well
his mom remember his mom's extremely
clean uh like just a neat freak and also
they interviewed her afterwards and she
is adamant
on him his innocence and says that he
should be released yeah
she's insane too mentally i'm one of
those moms yeah she's like she threw an
enabler
clean freak thing i mean how does that
tie in to uh extreme control
and now who's defensive
i don't see one with codependency issues
and clean freak issues she's like i'm
not gonna have a
serial killer and if i do they're
innocent okay
let's see how that ties into it as she
cleans
the table i know right there's a little
stain on the table
so she was a control freak clean freak
right and like i said
she threw his bunnies out in the winter
and he saw them freeze to death out
there
so this was already kind of like a
[ __ ] up he he was he was not
yeah i yeah not a stranger to death from
a very young age yeah yeah
it's so it's almost weird that now that
you put a face to the person i almost
feel bad for him
because it looks like your brother yeah
and your little
your issues are coming up maybe
oh like i feel bad for him that he like
is
i think anyone that feels bad for
somebody who murdered someone
should be arrested electric chair
take me in officer i deserve to die
father was schizophrenic also
and uh it was claimed that luca was also
schizophrenic
can you explain exactly what that means
because all i know is that
people hear voices but like what else is
it schizophrenia from what i understand
is like you hear
very very intrusive voices like you
can't do anything because all you hear
is like
these like hundreds what voice is
telling you like you should probably go
kill them right now
oh we're like are you holding that club
a cup right now you just smash it over
his face and just
all these very intrusive voices and you
don't know what's real or what's
not real anymore you know from but
that's what from what i
understand and what it is so more into
his childhood uh
so his dad was schizophrenic and then
his mom apparently remarried and had a
step dad that abused him a lot
i knew it yeah i knew there was going to
be abuse a lot that's true
i mean humans just don't seem to be born
this [ __ ] up
right uh there are some stories of
little children who just all of a sudden
start killing
even though their childhood was fine so
i'm not really sure they were dropped in
the head or something maybe or there was
like a
someone that the parents didn't know
about that was maybe abusing them
yeah yeah some sort of brain damage
because i i started watching
um like a few years ago i was watching
people's channels who had just
a dissociative identity disorder and you
know that's
always caused by trauma in childhood
some like very traumatic event starts it
and this one channel that i was watching
the mom had no idea that this
because when she first like they were
trying to figure out what was
happening with her daughter and they
couldn't figure it out and then the
doctor was like i think she has did and
the mom was like wait but
she never had any trauma in her
childhood and then
they did like a hypnosis on her and like
it came out that this
really traumatic thing happened and they
know who the person is and stuff
um they didn't disclose that they didn't
on the channel
the person who did the abuse admitted
they didn't they didn't go into that
because this was
just her youtube channel where they
talked about how they discovered
her the ideas my only thing is like with
that
um sometimes those hypnosis things like
they've had
reports come out like since that they're
like yeah they're just like
creating fake memories or something so
i'm like if
did they actually find this person of
guilty of abuse or
did because in the 80s that was a big
thing too like a therapist
they confronted this person and so i'm
guessing
that part got resolved because they
didn't want to reveal his
identity or anything like that so yeah
but the mom and daughter were basically
explaining how it happened
and um the fascinating part was the mom
had no idea and this had been
like i think she got diagnosed when she
was like 12
so like 12 like that long had gone by
the signs
um so she had it's multiple
personalities
so you're this traumatic event you
there's so much trauma happening to you
it's such a
an age where you can't emotionally
process it or physically process it
um and you're you basically your
personality splits off into
different like people and some of the um
personalities are their whole job is to
hold on to the pain
so that the other personalities can live
and not have to remember the trauma that
happened
and with a lot of the personalities it's
like
created from the mind of the age that
that child was when the traumatic event
happened so
sometimes they have british accents or
like they'll be something really
immature
or like yeah like little kids or like
yeah old different lives like one's a
teacher yeah
kid or yeah basically it just splits
your personality into these segments
that that
you would have been as a whole person in
one personality
had this not happened to you but because
of that trauma it splintered off
into these different personalities
because one person couldn't handle
all of them yeah it just seems like in
general this guy's life was just not
okay um after being abused by his
stepdad he moved in with his grandmother
who was an absolute control freak also
and she started abusing him
there were several times when he ended
up in like crisis centers trying to get
help
um he grew up and then i it was like he
he really wanted
to change himself so much to become
something so perfect
at the age of 20 he started stripping
and then he started prostituting himself
um and then he was quote gay for pay for
you know a lot a while
too i mean that sounds like a lot of
trouble youth
lifestyle though mm-hmm so um
oh i actually have a video of the last
known footage of his victim
it was a cctv footage of those to the
apartment those two going into the
apartment buildings
so this is footage of jin lin his last
known footage
of him going into luca's apartment so
jin lin is
in a yellow t-shirt
oh that's sad he looks comfortable like
he has that weird hair interesting yeah
yeah luca has that long hair
and after the murder had taken place
already there was videos of luca going
to
throw out his trash he's wearing and
he's wearing the victim's t-shirt
what yeah yeah yeah wasn't he like
trying to
dump something in the dumpster he was
trying to dump something in the
dumpster while wearing his t-shirt it's
like a trophy
sick yeah i'm so fascinated by how their
brains work i remember reading
a study where they hook them up to these
things on their brains to see which part
of the brain fires off
when you talk about certain things to
them uh for instance like there's a
there's one where there's a taxi driver
and you ask him okay where's this
building and then
he starts you know naming off like this
is where you go you turn right here
you turn right over here whatever and
there's like a part of your brain that
you know activates you see everything
firing off in there
um but with with murders like this
uh so for instance tiff i would tell you
one thing like tiffany i really like
your shirt where'd you get it from so
one part of your brain starts firing off
when you're telling me this information
like recall yeah okay
and then and then i'll bring up
something else like really traumatic
like tiffany how do you feel about rape
pedophiles murders and then that
will trigger another part of your brain
right but with
people like this the same part that has
like the mundane like oh this is where i
got my outfit that's where they
their brain fires off when they're
talking about murders and like terrible
crazy so
emotionally detached it's normal for
them it sits in the normal part of their
brain when they're talking
isn't that strange yeah the strangest
thing like it's just an everyday thing
it's like it's like a
cup of water for them yeah it's just
they're just discussing a normal
everyday thing so they know it's only
it's wrong logically
but not like in their head it's not
really like a big deal
yeah like it's just they don't see it as
we do like dude that's really wrong but
for them it's like no this is like a
tuesday for me like does that make it
seem more scary
or less scary knowing that like they're
literally just doing something that they
think is normal
more scary it's way more scary yeah to
me
yeah because someone that knows it's
wrong or like feels that it's wrong and
like carries guilt about it
they're less likely to want to do it
again or like
yeah you know those there's things
holding them back from doing
those actions right there's like there's
like zero there's zero
yeah like consider the level of
like emotional energy that it would take
like for someone like me who knows
murder's wrong to actually murder
someone
and like kind of go through with that
act like knowing
that it's wrong or like like knowing
emotionally how
strong of an energy that is versus
someone who just
doesn't really feel anything and they're
just like poking a person
like doesn't it seem like i'm more evil
because like i emotionally understand
that too
no i feel like in your case it would be
um
something of more of like a like heat of
the moment kind of thing
that would even drive you yeah yeah that
would even drive your already
feeling like you would never want to
murder somebody then either you were
manipulated into it
or there was something that drove you
like heat of the moment or you were
under the influence of something but
like you're more likely not but if
you're
normal quote unquote then you're
you would live with guilt like you would
have guilt and stuff
and if you don't live with guilt then
you never thought it was wrong
anyway right yeah it's just
i would be more afraid of someone who
thinks murder is such an everyday thing
as opposed to someone's like i know it's
wrong but at that very moment i
snapped and that's it yeah but this
first people see it as like an empty
shell
like a robot kind of accidentally cut
like a car accidentally hit you
versus like actual an actual devil
person
it's like i know how bad this is and i'm
still going to go through with the
murder see i think that evil lives in
the shell person
yeah like nothing lives in them does
that make sense
i feel like they're an empty vessel for
evil to go through right
yeah i could do that's what i think if
you could walk away from just killing
someone or
stabbing them i ice pick like that's
pure evil yeah whether or not
you feel like it's a normal part of your
brain or whatever
like you know what you're doing is wrong
you know he knew it was gonna get on the
news
he knows what he's doing wrong and he's
like he's like
gleeful about it he didn't seem scared
not something he didn't seem scared or
like he would have like a mental
breakdown
exactly i feel like if i were to murder
someone i would eventually have a mental
breakdown because i would be constantly
paranoid
like yeah he wanted to get caught and he
would join these facebook groups that
were
eager to catch him and he would leave
little like
clues like come and get what if you do
yeah
he would tease them um but i really
gotta give props to that that whole
facebook team like they they
really were on it the main woman who was
speaking
in the documentary was incredible what
she did
and and watching it was just like oh
i wish i was a part of this group
because you guys know i love finding
people for sure but also do you remember
the part where
they talk about how luca found out
where this woman lived and he actually
like
sent her something to get her away yeah
see that's the part of me that like i
love i have a detective brain too and i
like love putting pieces together and
figuring stuff out and doing escape
rooms and all that stuff
but i could never go into that field
because like you're so like being
detective
involved in these evils and these people
and like that that tight-knit crime
community too
yeah i'm not gonna try to catch you
leave me alone yeah yeah i'm too tired
we're just gonna talk about it after the
fact
yeah but don't like this don't don't you
like this publicity don't enjoy this
don't enjoy it i don't want to know that
he's watching this all right
we're going to make another drink and uh
we if you want to see more
episodes like this um let us know in the
comments
let us know uh what you think about this
whole thing if you think that evil is
present in in normal people or if i mean
evil's present and everybody i think i
think so
but um if you think that it's more evil
to know what you're doing is wrong and
do it then
or if it's more evil that if you're a
shell of a human and yeah
you still seem to feel like they're
missing programming that's my argument
mm-hmm
this is why there's some coding or like
see the
the fact that abuse is consistent in
these people's childhoods is like
something traumatic maybe snapped that
part of yeah it's like having uh it's
like that
what's that uh football um right
heading through the questions uh crt you
know what they call it
cr or something you guys know what it is
i thought it is
it's not crt i don't know no wait
something else
we'll figure it out anyways
but yeah brain damage thanks for
watching this episode of murder
mystery news it's at this episode good
night we love you mm-hmm
on the next episode of
this one this one this one was some
yeah thanks for letting me host i really
enjoyed this i remember yeah a little
[Laughter]
we'll see you next week we love you bye
i'm normal